I've always known that I was attracted
to guys to people of the same sex since
I was a little kid and I I was raised
without any religion I mean as a matter
of fact I used to get Jesus and Santa
confused when I was a child
so I was raised without religion and I
didn't go to school I mean I didn't go
to high school I didn't go to junior
high school for any length of time so I
and then at a very early age I was
plunged into this extraordinary living
situation when I was when my mother gave
me to her her psychiatrist and his
family to live so my sexual orientation
was nothing I ever questioned or
struggled with or thought about it just
why I'm right-handed
you know I'm right-handed and it's just
a fact you know so being gay was exactly
the same thing it was just a fact and
it's always been like that for me in my
career and all my life I never I've
never I've never been something I
struggled with you know I've been asked
and I've actually been criticized by
some people in who have misinterpreted
when asked by the gay press are you
proud to be gay I have often replied I'm
not proud because I haven't accomplished
anything if I were if I had been the
child of evangelical Christian parents
I'd be damn proud you know if I had
worked for my identity I would be proud
but you know I never what did I do
you know I'm proud of the the gay and
lesbian people who came before me um and
made it possible for me to take it for
granted you know but I myself haven't
really haven't struggled and overcome
anything anyway I'm not I'm not proud of
being right-handed now at the same time
would I would I change and be straight
if I could never never no interest we
would never do it never do it so I'm
really happy you know this way but it's
not like I accomplished something I took
a driver's test and passed you know I
was just born knowing how to drive